what wears like a pimping I found that I
think dice is good it doesn't have a cup
holder welcome back to glamour with me
Josh engine house and today in the
immortal words of Jason Derulo we are
riding solo handsome self all then how
are you good how are you I'm good
well my favorite scenes in the film this
isn't giving it way too much is a set of
hilarious our scene yes I'm Chewie yes
is he just like a really great like
massive sponge but yeah and he smells
really good because they wash those
suits are all yak hair and they wash
them in shampoo and conditioner so he
actually smells great yeah so this is
great to have like a heat massive
walking talking sponge on that
absolutely I want to get some tips from
you about being more Star Wars in
everyday life
yes so got a couple of like real knife
scenarios grace when I get your opinions
on this yeah
now I want to awaken my own force on the
dancefloor what is a star was inspired
me if I could deploy some kind of
lightsaber
some kind would be the best way to go
yeah like a witch yeah yeah yeah I feel
like we could lost over some I think
he's a person he got this little dance
with the shoulders that's good I've been
a solo act singer for a while okay and I
haven't quite felt the force and become
a chart topper but Chewie has asked me
to perform a duo yes
this is really this is like my real life
is pretend this is my real life right
okay hyper cool real life which of
following songs do you recommend me
recording with him can't chew this chew
it real good or no tears left to chain I
think no tears left to cheer is good
yeah but Ariana if I could really work I
don't know I don't know she does like
the chewy yeah yeah yeah I guess so I
was going look at my test drive my own
Millennium Falcon
yes what do we need to look out for
there's a lot of buttons and you know
it's
I think it's good to keep it a little
bit on the junkie or looking sighs then
your people underestimate you you can
fly under the radar
well there's like a payment paying my
foul cat uh I think dice is good it
doesn't have a cup holder
you know it would be good to have that
like a lava lamp or something
oh yeah the 70s oh yeah take it back
that's right lava lamps about guys but
are they bad why did you have the kid
yeah I had one yeah I was like an
inflatable Chad G couple days as well
yes I had one for cup holder as well
which is really yes
well got a lava lamp and like black
lights and a strobe light in my room as
a team
oh wow it's like when I was like 11
action but you were very ready for Star
Wars by that long yeah great to meet you
[Music]